Mình quan đến vụ, gần ba chăm tất lợt bệnh tuần bà chờ, bế bán chừng học, ngày 1 tháng 12,
vô í tế có văn bàn người các địa phương đến gỷ tăng kương kiểm tra giám sát và bảo đam an toàn thực phẩm tại các bé ăn tập thế,
đặc biệt là bé ăn bán chú và chừng học.
Văn bàn gió thí trường vô í tế độ xun tuyên kỷ nêu gió, thời gian qua,
các quan chức năng đã phát hiện nhiều vụ thu góng, văn chuyển, giết mổ và tíu thủ lợt mắt bệnh,
với quy mô lớn tại một số địa phương.
Tinh trạng này tạo điều kiện để sản phẩm độ vật không bảo đam về sinh tuy,
không ăn tòàn thực phẩm lọt ra thị trường, trong đó cũng trò các bé bán tập thế, bà gồm cả chừng học.
Thử hiện công biển số 2 xấu 2 xấu 2 xấu của thu bệnh chi vụ,
về chấn trình công tác kìm trẻ ăn tòàn thực phẩm,
bối tế đề nghỉ các tình thành phố chỉ đảo các cơ quan chức năng,
tăng kực giềm tra giám sát các cơ sở bé bếp ăn tập thế,
kì thời phát hiện và sử lý nghiêm các đi phạm,
đồng thời không 2 thông tin để kẻ bảo cuộc đồng.
Cái để phương công cần đề mạnh phyến chuyên,
năng cao ý thức tuyên thuộc quy định với ăn tòàn thực phẩm,
yêu cầu các đên vị cũng cấp suốt ăn,
phải bà đam đầy đủ điều kiện về sinh trong phản bộ qua chiến chế biến,
phục vụ và có khả năng truy xuất của nguốc thực phẩm khi cần thiết,
chú đoống phương ăn phòng và sử lý khi xảy ra ngổ lột thực phẩm.
Đối với các cơ sở giáo dục có tổ chức mếp ăn, căng tin,
bối tế yêu cầu thực hiện nghiêm các quy định hành về ăn tòàn thực phẩm,
năng cao chức nghiệm của người đứng đầu,
tăng cường tin chuyên kiến thức phòng người chống mộ lột cho giáo viên học sinh,
vì đồng sự thăm ra ăn giám giám giám xác của phủ viên và các tổ chức trong nhà trường.
Bối tế đình nghĩ các địa phương trên khai nghiêm tốt các nỗi dùng nếu trên,
nhằm bảo đam ăn tòàn thực phẩm,
bà vẻ sức khoảng người dân và hạnh chế tối đang quyết cơ sảy ra các vụ một độc tập thế.
Chức đó bộ y tế đã cửa cung văn săng bộ rất dục vào đầu tạo,
cung văn chỉ đạo linh ngành và ăn tòàn thực phẩm các tình thành phố,
về việc tăng cường kiểm tra gám xác và bà đam ăn tòàn thực phẩm tại các nước ăn tập thế,
bếp ăn bán chú và chương học.